bonjour le bulletin de santé de françois
mitterrand fêtait à ce matin de lésions
cancéreuses mais a priori pas de quoi
s'alarmer le président se rétabli
normalement dit-on de l'opération qu'il
a subie il ya cinq jours il devrait
quitter l'hôpital cochin aujourd'hui et
reprendre ses activités après une brève
convalescence et le bulletin de santé
précise que les examens ont révélé la
présence de cellules cancéreuses à
l'hôpital cochin pascal mitraille tout
de suite tout de suite l'hôpital cochin
alors un petit problème avec ce
reportage il va arriver dans quelques
secondes des aigus blair est clair on a
découvert des lésions cancéreuses sur
les tissus prélevés lors de l'opération
du président de la république il y a
cinq jours on vient de découvrir après
une intervention chirurgicale et avec un
examen histologique qu'il y avait des
lésions qui n'était pas bénigne donc on
ne peut pas être plus clair le président
décide que ne peut pas être plus clair
que cela il ya des lésions qui sont des
lésions que mon appel cancéreux si vous
avez mieux être dans une forme de cancer
assez typique de la prostate et que ces
lésions se situe au sein du tissu
prostatique avec je vis je me répète des
examens biologiques qui montrent en
particulier les phosphatase à site
prostate et koutat retraite la mine
comme on les appelle qui sont normales
donc c'est ce qui veut dire on a
effectivement je ne répète encore une
lésion cancéreuse mais qui est classique
si je puis dire ça se soigne je viens de
me réveiller pas là par un traitement
médical qui n'empêche pas le patient
d'avoir son activité je pense qu'il ya
en france des milliers de dôngs est une
maladie de l'homme et qui ont ce
traitement et qui poursuivent leur
activité tout à fait normalement